[Music]
this morning on the dish star of the San
Diego dining scene Anthony Wells was
born far from the west coast in the
mountain state of West Virginia heading
off the culinary school in San Francisco
with just 18 years old he scored jobs at
some top restaurants including Thomas
Keller's per say here in New York before
becoming executive chef at San Diego's
Juniper and Ivy with an emphasis on
fresh-cut local seafood and seasonal
ingredients it's also known for plated
dishes that are works of art and was
just recognized with a big gourmand
award from the famed Michelin Guide and
chef Anthony Wells good morning to you
welcome to the dish thank you it's great
to be here describe all this business
here so we have a few dishes that we
serve at the restaurant we have
barbecued carrots we make a little
chimichurri with the tops of the carrots
oh that's cool
some pickled apricots and some toasted
peanuts there's a roasted potatoes with
a cheddar cheese sauce some pickled
onions and some fried potatoes that
kinda remind you of the bottom of the
Lay's potato chip a little version of
linguini and clams with creamed corn
some smoked pork belly a little bit of
shrimp and Calabrian chilies and then we
have a whole roasted chicken with a
smoked almond salsa verde and dessert
and dessert of course they sticky toffee
pudding cake is this and a passion fruit
gin and tonic Oh Cheers actually I've
been telling cheers Cheers
so Anthony is it true that it was a TV
commercial that set you on this path in
the culinary world yes we missed here
sort of yeah it was a TV show chef
Richard Blais was when he was on Top
Chef he was pretty big inspiration to me
and I when he won I just really wanted
to work with him and so I sent him an
email and sure enough he replied within
a couple hours and I moved to Atlanta
and
the rest was history okay what did that
email say it basically it was just
congratulations on winning the show I've
kind of followed the whole season
I loved all of your little quirkiness
and your thoughtfulness of food you grew
up in West Virginia right but this I
mean it but you've you've brought this
left coast cooking you know into your
life and into your business now because
this certainly looks more like San Diego
cooking I think well we just have
wonderful product 365 days a year
and we at the restaurant we've just made
a lot of wonderful relationships and
they just bring us top-of-the-line
product every day so it's the menu just
writes itself
you've been credited with changing or
recreating modern Southern Californian
cuisine or establishing it I think
establishing it yeah helping it out yes
and how did you do it I mean what is it
that's different
I'm just persistency you know it's a lot
of hard work and you got to know the
right people and you got to be able to
get ahold of the right people and you
need to be willing to use their product
whether they have a ton of product that
day Wow or a little bit of product that
day but we through the good times and
the bad times we're always very
supportive of of all of the local
fishermen and farmers sustainability
it's been a really big thing for you oh
absolutely that's so important to you if
not the food's gonna run out so we need
to make sure that we're utilizing every
little bit of whether it's the carrot or
the fish or the pig so we just try and
utilize those odds and ends that
normally most restaurants don't use and
yeah we're pretty we got pretty good at
creating beautiful dishes out of them
what is it that you love about cooking
probably just the camaraderie of working
with all of the the men and women in the
kitchen it's we've really created a
family atmosphere at juniper and ivy and
just I get excited to see the guys and
girls every day and it's just it's it's
special when it all comes together
I'm gonna have you sign the dish and ask
you if you could have this meal of
anyone past or present who would it be
well the owner of the restaurant wanted
me to come on this so much so I want to
give a shout out to Mike Rosen and if I
could sit down and have this meal with
anybody it would be you Mike I wish Mike
and Anthony coming to a restaurant near
you that's right chef Anthony Wells
thank you very much and if you want more
on Chef Wells or the dish you can head
to our website at CBS this morning
dot-com